hey what's up guys my name is a Chino
and welcome to episode 12 of network
chat programming so today we're going to
more or less talk about receiving data
okay not sending receiving data now the
way that our the way that this works is
um is a thing is I feel like I should do
an in-depth episode that really explains
things like ports and everything too
because I know that a lot of you guys
are networking pros and it does
certainly help to know you know what a
port is what an address is how I'm you
know what sockets are and how that stuff
interacts but for the sake of time I'm
going to kind of skip over a lot of this
stuff I will explain it roughly but um
again I I may make it in fact I'm pretty
sure I will make basically just one of
episodes to cover all these concepts
such as a ports for example sockets and
how they all interact basically what
happens is on this diagram socket that
this diagram socket that we've created
that's responsible for our managing I
guess a connection to the network I
talked about this last episode but you
can see over here in the constructor
we've left blank and that's absolutely
fine by the way what this will do is if
we are actually mouse over we'll see the
nice Java doc here it will say it tells
us that it constructs the diagram socket
and binds it to any available port on
the local host machine now the reason
I've left does that is because um
occasionally what will happen is a what
well essentially what will happen is
ports might not be available so in other
words on your computer you know the port
20 5560 might might not be available but
it will be on mine because you might
bring it running an application we've
written your own application that uses
that port so it's advisable to not do
that but then again you know we are we
are if we go back to this log in Java
and we actually take a little what it
looks like in the GUI side I probably
should show up in the application
would've been faster than this passing
thing um sorry my Mac isn't very fast
it's a MacBook Pro from 2010 so give it
a break okay so we've got this port
right and that's there for a reason
right I'm surprised actually Nonpoint
so what we do is when we actually do hit
the login button what we do is we rub
the port here and we pass it on to the
login method here which in turn actually
launches a new client with port as a
parameter we're not doing anything with
that parameter at the moment we're
passing it into this connect thing over
here but what I'm actually using in here
so let's just put it into the parameter
here and what this will do is this will
actually construct us a Datagram socket
based on that port so instead of being
any available port it's going to be that
specific port okay and that helps us a
lot so now let's talk about how
receiving works okay because that's a to
say the least that's some not the
easiest thing to UM is all about but I
think it's I think sending is actually
actually a lot easier than receiving to
be honest but regardless we're going to
do receiving first so we'll make it a
we'll make it private because I mean you
don't need to make a public private
string receive oops okay and it's not
going to take any parameters but it is
going to return a string and this string
will be the thing that we receive so I'm
doing receiving first not sending and
there is I'm doing that is because
sending sending is a bit more involved
as in we we actually handle sending we
we're more or less with sending we
handle sending in the app in innocent ID
in that actual method whereas receive we
kind of do half the stuff in the method
and half the stuff when we call the
method so that'll make sense to you
eventually but um for now we need a way
to receive something how does that work
well first of all I didn't mention
packets didn't I
packets are essentially just groups of
bytes they're groups of data now to
receive to receive this data this packet
in in using the data Graham socket here
we actually need to make an object
called a Datagram packet okay so a
Datagram packet well we'll just call a
packet oops
diagram packet packet equals new diagram
packet and then it'll take two
parameters for us it Allah it will only
take okay so it has to take an array of
bytes okay so in other words when we're
receiving a packet of data
we're receiving an array of bytes okay
so you know in in Java and other
programming languages there are there's
a vast amount of methods that actually
do things like strings into by
conversion so in other words if we want
to send send the message hello we don't
have to know you know the numerical
value of that we can just simply use
this string to bind or whatever is
called two byte array or two bytes
I think it is to actually convert that
string into bytes but since we're
receiving we'll just make an array of
bytes here so byte data equals new byte
and we'll set it will make 1024 of them
okay we'll make 1024 less two to the
power of 10 bytes okay so that that
should be enough okay you could make
this bigger but the thing that you would
argue as well is that you really don't
want to be sending back I said a modern
this size I do realize that Java will
probably split them up for you but still
you don't want to keep track you don't
want to keep track of more than that
many bytes um which is essentially a
kilobyte of data here you know as you
say as you send it so okay so now that
we've made this we can pass in data as a
parameter and we also need to specify a
length okay so in other words this is
kind of like the the range of the of the
bytes that works once and we want to
send all of them right so I'll receive
sorry we want to receive be entire we
just want to fill the entire array with
data here so we'll type in dart length
okay cool
so let's import this we just hover our
mouse over here Eclipse will do that for
us so it's like in Java net diagram
packet and and there we go
no errors awesome so now that we've got
that we actually need to receive this
data somehow okay this is in receiving
data what does this done as its created
a packet this packet is currently empty
we need to fill it with data we can do
that by calling socket which is our data
Graham socket which remember is our
actual connection to the network
socket receive and then we actually need
to dump the data somewhere so we put it
into our packet okay awesome
so assuming that this does actually
receive something we get a packet of
data away from this so we need to try
and catch this because um it does throw
an eye on an i/o exception as uh as you
would imagine because it is to do with
input/output let support that hang on oh
yeah cool so will uh what guess will be
a nice and bertha stack trace okay cool
so now that we've done that we've
essentially got this packet of data now
but what we kind of want to put it into
and is a string format right because
we're returning a string so we'll make
in brand-new string here and we'll call
it a message because you know we will be
receiving messages as the entire point
of this application and we'll make it
equal to new string okay packet dot get
data and that's it okay so it's just new
string packet data very very simple so
what package get data we'll do is
essentially as you can see a return and
array of bytes so what we've done is
we've created an array of bytes okay
think of it as we've just created a
bunch of data okay one kilobyte of data
here we've um we've made a packet to
store that data okay we've we've
actually we've listened and we've
received a packet from the network and
remember this will actually hang the
program this is the other important
thing this socket don't receive will sit
there until it receives something okay
which is why we're going to talk about
threads in the next um episode but this
will actually this receive call right
here this will actually freeze our
application okay because what is going
to do is it's essentially a what is a
lot and I'm not sure if I can show you
this because I don't think I have the
source attached here but essentially
what socket don't receive is is it's
like a while true loop almost it's only
while true but it's a while loop the
keeps going until it actually
gets some data from the network on to
this specific port that we've bound here
when we've created this diagram socket
which is right over and here actually
you know what let's put receive let's
say let's put receive below the UM the
open connection method here okay
so we've created this diagram socket on
this port and this receive method will
actually just it'll just wait for data
on that port if the Dynamo comes just
until we close the application it's
never going to stop waiting and then
once it does receive something okay once
it does receive data it's going to pop
it into this packet okay and then we can
use packet get data to get that original
array that is now filled with bytes and
what we're doing here is we're creating
a new string out of it so we're
essentially converting these bytes into
a string and then finally we'll return
the string so we'll return message okay
awesome
so that is the receive method okay it's
a bit um maybe a bit complicated here
but I think I think it's probably a bit
more complicated the send method consent
is easy right all you do is you make it
you make a are you essentially just make
a arm you get you get your data that you
want to send then you just send it to
into an address into a port and it's
really easy but here there's this whole
aspect of how socket or receive works so
if we were to do something like put
receive into I don't know into open
connection or something we'll just put
receive some way if we were to do that
it's actually going to essentially
freeze our application okay because
remember with concurrency I really don't
want to talk about this now she talked
about this in the next episode but
what's going to happen is this socket
receiver is going to take up the entire
process because of course when we
execute commands you know when when the
computer execute our code and go
sequentially when I guess the socket
don't receive it says okay that's pretty
much a while loop there so I'm going to
wait until I get data okay and it's just
going to sit there until it gets its
data it's not going to execute the rest
of the program
so we'll be in trouble there but luckily
threads will come to the rescue in the
next episode when we implement the send
method so I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of network chat programming if
you did please hit like button 200 likes
on a video per day 300 likes to videos
per day ok so again if you did enjoy the
video please hit like button and I'll
see you guys next time good bye
you